And now the old scout master.
You know, scouting has actually changed one of my little evaluation methods for whether
I want to take advice from somebody.
And my new question is: have they made more mistakes than I have?
But if they have made fewer mistakes than I have, then they probably do not know more.
Well, that's probably why people listen to us, Walter is because,
Yes, we have decades,
Decades put all together,
We have what about five or six decades of mistakes.
You're being very kind.
Hey, this is podcast number 136..
Hey,
Well, welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Hey, let's look in the mailbag.
It's pretty full. this week.
Victor Vergoli is a scout master with Troop 244.
And he writes in to say thanks for posting ten ways to help a senior patrol leader.
I'm a new scout master here in Warner Robins, Georgia, and we have a new senior patrol leader.
I'll put these to good use.
Also, enjoy your weekly podcasts.
I've gleaned valuable info from them.
Keep up the good work.
Well, thanks for being in touch, Victor.
Kind words certainly appreciate it.
Here's a couple of comments from Podcast 135..
Walter Torres wrote in to say the piece with the Charlie Brown voices was just great.
That's what I needed.
Larry Geiger joined him and said: I loved it.
You turned Charlie Brown upside down with the wah-wah-wah being the kid instead of the adult.
I felt so very clever.
Bill McFarlane wrote back in again and he said: hmm, doesn't Frank Maynard run Bob White's Blather
Great blog? but I can't take credit for it.
My blog is channeling Whittle and Jim.
Besides being a scout master, I'm a bear, and a good old bear too.
Hey,
Hey, Bill,
You know I figured out that somehow in my adult brain I have Bill McFarlane and Frank Maynard,
two completely different names. but somehow I've got the wires crossed there.
Frank, I apologize.
Go visit Frank and see Bob White's Blather blog.
Frank does a wonderful job with that,
As does Bill over at channeling Whittle and Jim.
Bill is carving necker chip slides and things like that over there.
So go check those guys out.
And thanks, Bill, for setting me straight.
Gary Downey is a scout master in Troop 1 of Blackstone, Massachusetts,
And he says: Clark, I love your site so much so I added it to a slide in my scout master's
specific training so people have your web address.
Over the last several years I have trained over 200 adults that boys run the Troop,
not the adults.
The look of horror from some of the participants is priceless.
I feel my main job is to give boys a safe place and environment to make mistakes.
If they never make mistakes, they'll never really learn anything.
Well, thank you, Gary.
Thanks for being in touch
And I'm glad that you're finding the blog and podcast useful,
And thanks for spreading the word.
Really do appreciate that.
Mark Bauer in San Diego wrote. I wanted to tell you about our troops experience
at Fillmont this summer.
Our troop had 15 scouts and six adults which were split into two separate track groups.
We did short tracks that last about a week.
That makes it much easier to get adults that can take that amount of vacation time.
This may be an option for other troops as opposed to the full 12-day Fillmont tracks,
which may not be doable because of adults needing to take that much vacation time.
We went out on the trail as the last track of the season.
It was much nicer to be one of four tracks in a campsite or activity
instead of one of 19 or 20..
The late season weather at Fillmont was fantastic.
We had thunderstorms like clockwork, starting about 2 in the afternoon,
but they kept the dust down and, compared to the drier earlier part of the summer.
we really enjoyed ourselves.
Well. thanks, Mark, for that report.
It sounds like you had a wonderful time out there
and hopefully that'll be helpful to people as they plan their trips to Fillmont.
In this podcast we're finally back on schedule.
It's September.
We're not running all over the place on camping trips and stuff like that.
All the kids are back and that regular schedule starts to kick in.
So we have our September Scoutmaster panel discussion coming up
And in this panel discussion we have a guest.
His name is Enoch and we'll tell you a little bit more about Enoch.
I realized as I was editing the panel discussion
I did not point out something important.
This is something that has to deal with youth protection.
Enoch is 17 years old,
He's a life scout in his troop
and you'll understand how we got in touch with him
and everything here in a minute.
But just as a youth protection measure,
we made sure to get in touch with Enoch's parents
and we also made sure to copy them on all the emails and things like that
and to double check and make sure you had their permission
and they understood what was going on.
So, just in case you listen to the panel discussion and you wonder,
there you go, and just in case that wasn't on your radar screen
so far as emailing back and forth with youth members in scouting,
remember that you want to include a carbon copy
to another adult leader or their parents or something like that.
And that's just an observation of no one-on-one communications
between adult leaders and scouts.
So we're going to get to the Scoutmaster panel discussion in just a minute,
but first I've got this for you:
If a Scoutmaster speaks in a forest and there are no scouts around,
do they still ignore him?
It's true, adult leaders say the same things over and over and over again.
Now, tragically, much of this wisdom has gone unrecorded.
That is until now, because, through the miracle of modern technology,
we're going to capture 200 phrases that adult leaders say
over and over again,
And we're going to do that on the stuff adult leaders say t-shirt,
A t-shirt just for us.
That's right. 200 phrases that adult leaders say over and over again
on a great t-shirt.
Go to scoutsmastercgcom and follow the link right there
on the front page to a t-shirt just for us,
And there you'll find out about my Kickstarter project
and how it works and, most importantly, how to get a t-shirt
for yourself and your fellow adult leaders:
Hurry, because the project is going to close on September 30th
at 11 pm eastern standard time.
Now what's really exciting is you can help decide
what 200 phrases are going on the shirt.
You can offer your suggestions or comments at scoutsmastercgcom.
Once again, look for the t-shirt just for us link.
You'll get all the information you need
and it'll lead you to the Kickstarter project
so you can make sure to pledge and get your stuff.
adult leaders say t-shirt,
It's a t-shirt just for us.
So the project just launched just an hour or so ago
and the backers we have so far are Edward Bruce,
Adam Cox, Bill McMahon, Jill Blanche and James Murphy.
Thank you so much, folks, for pledging on kickstartercom
for the stuff. adult leaders say t-shirt.
So as I'm speaking right now, people are e-mailing in
and telling us what goes on the t-shirt and things.
This is going to be great fun,
But we've got a Scoutmaster panel discussion to present,
so let's get started, shall we?
It's time for another Scoutmaster panel discussion.
So it's time for another Scoutmaster panel discussion.
and here we are again, and we've got a couple of our regulars.
Larry Geiger is down there in Vieira, Florida.
How are you doing Larry?
Hey Clark doing good,
And Walter Underwood is out there in the wilds
of Northern California somewhere.
How are you doing, Walter?
We had a tiny bit of rain- it's what they call it here,
but we probably not call it rain-
And it's probably unconscionably cool
and beautiful there while we're still sweltering
in the early September heat.
I apologize,
And joining us today is Enoch,
And Enoch is a 17-year-old life scout.
I'll tell you that Enoch is from Texas
and he came to our attention because he has a blog
called Scouting Rediscovered.
If you're a follower of the blog and the podcast,
you've seen some links to Enoch's blog
and you saw an article that he was kind enough
to write for us about adult leaders
from a scout's perspective.
And Enoch, we're pleased to have you
Well. thanks for having me. I really appreciate it.
Enoch got in touch with me and he was interested
in writing an article for the blog,
and I looked at Scouting Rediscovered
and it was a really impressive job.
You really do need to get over and see that,
And there'll be a link to Enoch's blog
in the post that contains this podcast
at ScoutmasterCGcom.
I asked if he would write about his perspective
of adult leaders as a scout.
Enoch you talk about when you first join your troop
really not what to expect
Now. were you in Cubs at all
or Weeblows at all before you became a Boy Scout?
I was not. Actually, I didn't join Boy Scouts
right whenever I was 11 or 12.
I didn't really know anything about Boy Scouts
until I was 13.
And a friend from church told me about it
and he was an adult
and he used to be a scout master himself
and he gave me a book
and I started reading through it
and I really liked what I saw
and eventually that led to me
becoming a scout at 13..
So not quite the normal joining age, but
Can you identify any specific things
that made you think this was something
that you wanted to do?
Well, I can't really pin down
anything exactly in particular.
It's not like I actually
thought through it real logically,
but I was just reading the book
and it was the 11th edition
of the Scout Handbook at that time
and I really liked just the whole structure
of the organization.
It just sounded like a lot of fun
and the opportunities
to go on the camping trips and stuff
was a really big motivator for me.
The former scout master
that first introduced me to scouting-
he went on a camping trip with me
and me and my dad and a few other families
and kind of introduced me
to that form of scout camping trip stuff
and I was hooked after that first camping trip
I really loved it.
Did you know anybody in the scout trip
that you joined?
I did not.
They were all new to me
and there wasn't a scout troop,
and there still isn't a scout troop
in the town that I live. so it was a town near to me
and I didn't really know anybody at all.
So you get started,
you join a troop
and what happens from there?
How big was the troop that you joined?
It was around 20..
So it was fairly small, small size,
small town troop.
I didn't really hold any
leadership positions right off the bat.
there was quite a few that were
a couple of years older than me in the troop.
so I was mostly just kind of hanging out
and just observing everything
and I was going on the camping trips,
participating and all that,
and pretty soon I started to
start to advance in the ranks
fairly quickly.
I guess, I don't know,
maybe I was a little bit more motivated,
maybe my dad helped me out with this,
helped me be motivated,
but I really sat through
and wanted to read the scout handbook,
so I read it from cover to cover. actually
I think it was in my first year there
and that really helped me
pass an awful lot of the rank requirements
and advancing and I ended up
becoming patrol leader of my patrol
and then actually ended up
becoming senior patrol leader
and held that position for about a year. so
How did you figure out how to be a patrol leader?
When I joined, you know, there was
already. there was a fair,
fair patrol structure
and there were definite patrol leaders and stuff,
so they
basically had a.
I can't really remember.
it's been a while
and so much stuff has happened,
but I don't really remember if I was elected
or if just the older
scout who was the patrol leader
left that and I was
the next kind of in line, so to speak.
I can't really remember it was either one of those two, so
So you kind of picked it up from what you had seen.
Yeah, yeah,
basically at that point
I hadn't really been doing any
extra reading about scouting or anything like that,
just what I had in the
scout handbook
and what I saw in my troop.
So patrol leader for a while, and then you moved on.
Well, I was just saying
that I had been a patrol leader actually for quite a while
and I really enjoyed
working with my patrol
and I started to have-
which no other patrol in my troop had done this-
but I started to have patrol meetings
with my patrol, separate patrol meetings
apart from the troop meetings.
so I remained a patrol leader for quite a while
and it was about a year ago actually
that I was- oh well, a little over a year-
a little over a year ago that I was
actually just decided to run for the senior
patrol leader elections and at that point
I was one of the senior scouts in the troop
and so
I think I won with a pretty good margin,
And
so you spend a year as a senior
patrol leader. how did that go for you?
I started out, you know,
fairly routine, and so
first I just kind of filled
in the shoes of the previous senior
patrol leader and
I didn't try to do a whole lot
different. but
then I started to try to do more
patrol leader council meetings.
I tried to introduce those regularly
because they hadn't happened
in my troop really before that,
and I started doing a lot of different things,
trying to transition
more power to the patrol leaders
and more responsibility to the patrol leaders,
and some of that went well.
this
didn't go so well, so
I had its ups and downs, but I really learned a lot.
Yes, so we're
all curious about what did not go well,
because we're used to things
not going well as outmasters.
Well,
a couple things.
right after I had joined,
my troop had lost
some of the older boys that were originally
in my kind of generation of the troop.
a lot of those had started to leave
because they got older or
just weren't really active anymore,
and so just as I
got
elected as senior patrol leader,
there was a whole new influx of
like
12 scouts
fresh out of cub scouts,
so there was a lot of these
really younger boys.
I was 16
at the time, so there were
11 and 12,
and so I didn't really
know quite what to do and there was
a bit of chaos at first. so that was one of the
difficulties I had to go through.
the young scouts
had
their difficulties and
had to mature up a little bit and
stuff like that. so
that was one of the difficulties.
another of the difficulties was
that
I read about the
new scout patrol and the concept of the new scout
patrol in the scout handbook.
so I wanted to try that out
and so
one group of the new scouts
of like six or seven
I had set apart
to be part of the new scout patrol-
actually two of the patrols,
since there was like 12,
12 new cub scouts,
I basically had all the older scouts
being two separate patrols and all the younger
scout being two separate patrols.
and that
wasn't really.
that wasn't really
smiled upon
by some of the adults
and the scouters who were running the troop,
because
there was a tendency for these
patrols to
get off focus a while
and get kind of wild at sometimes
that I tried to spend a lot of time talking
with them and helping and stuff but
it would and I knew it would take time
in order to kind of transition them to
a more mature scout patrol.
but
that was probably one of the main things
that they disagreed with me on.
they wanted them to be split up among
the other patrols
and have an older scout as the patrol leader
for each of those patrols.
so
I suppose I kind of disagreed with that
for several reasons. I guess
you probably don't want me to go through all the reasons now, but
that was one of the main challenges I had-
or confrontations, I guess you could say-
with the scouters in my troop.
so how did that turn out?
my scout master
had a certain thing where
he would have no one-
no senior patrol leader- run
two terms in a row.
so after
my first term
I wasn't allowed to run for re-election.
so the next in line
for me- because all of the older
scouts of my generation had by that time
pretty much moved on-
the next in line for me
were a couple years younger than me.
they were still kind of inexperienced
and they didn't really know a lot about
what I was trying to do with the troop.
and so once they had gotten elected,
the scout master
or several of the scouters came
and they decided that
they would go ahead and split up all the patrols
and stuff. so eventually
it did end up happening, but they did wait
till after I was not senior patrol leader anymore.
so I don't know if that's a good thing or a bad thing.
did you talk
to the new SPL
and patrol leaders about your philosophy?
did you try to pass
that down a little bit?
I did, I did,
I had kind of
I tried to have,
especially up to the time whenever the new election
was going to take place, I tried to have
as many patrol leader council meetings
that I could because
with a bit of the patrol leaders
and my assistant senior patrol leaders
I had two assistant senior patrol leaders,
so I tried to tell them during that time,
I guess, more about
my philosophy of the patrols
and how I had come to view them
and stuff, and to some extent
I do believe they absorbed it
and they took it in. but
also
they were more- the scouts
particular were less inclined to take things
as serious as I was
and they kind of just
would go along with the flow.
whenever the scout master kind of came
and said,
well, this is how it's going to be,
we got to do this or do that,
they kind of just went along with the flow
and, especially since they were new senior patrol leaders,
they wouldn't feel like
they wanted to come out and openly disagree
with the scout master. so,
okay,
there's some interesting,
a bunch of interesting questions here, because
our troop does not do
new scout patrols. but that's really
the decision of the PLC
and having lots of PLC meetings
is really important
and I think that's a great thing
that you've helped instill
on that troop.
we just reorganized
the patrols
because we have more scouts,
we have a ton of new scouts
and so we
do more instruction on the patrols
and so we like to have
older and younger scouts in the same patrols.
but that's
you know. there's really different ways to do it.
new scout patrols can work too,
so
I think it was
sounds great to push
for that and I think it's.
it sounds kind of like
you know the troop has won
and that you've got
more PLC meetings
and we're thinking
about the new scouts.
what we spend a lot of time doing
on the blog and on the podcast
is trying to give as much information
and ideas
and the benefit of
our experience is possible to
help people kind of sort their way through
some of the stickier parts
of working with youth leaders.
you sound
kind of like an ideal
youth leader in a lot of ways.
you had this kind of initiative
and this kind of passion
for making things happen
and
to me it's kind of.
it's a little sad that you
felt like you got thwarted there along the way,
but it's a pretty common thing actually.
well,
in the end,
if you'd been mentoring the SPL
and you guys had decided he was really strong
on doing it the other way.
that's fine with me.
the thing that I noted was
you said that they went along
with the scoutmasters.
well, maybe
the scoutmasters could have let you
and the SPL and the patrol leaders
kind of make that decision,
and I think
somebody shouldn't have
necessarily have to be really
direct- like maybe you were
on occasions-
to have that kind of freedom to do that.
if a guy is going to show
a lot of initiative and if he's going to really
move things forward
and he has a vision for the way this is going to work,
I can't
see anything but letting him follow that.
we're looking back on some years
of experience and we've been around the block a few times
so we understand that this is going to work.
what do we tell
Enoch's scout leader
when he's in the middle of this
and Enoch is just going great guns
and pushing forward
and he's shown all this initiative and everything like that?
what do we tell the
scoutmaster who's a little nervous
about this because he's never seen this before?
well,
if I could, I would say:
make sure you're doing the scout program,
but in the areas
of the program that's up to the boys,
leave it to them,
to the senior scout
and the SPL and the younger scouts
go out of the room and leave them alone.
when they go to organize patrols,
they get 12 new guys
leave.
so, guys, you got to deal with this
instead of then saying, well, I'm the scoutmaster
and I think
it ought to go this way.
do your best to let them make the decision
and work it out,
and that's to me that's key.
yeah, we
in our recent patrol reorganization,
the youth leaders
know the other boys so much better than I do
and
they're so careful
in organizing this.
you know, the signature mistake
when I was scoutmaster
was letting an adult
reorganize the patrols after the
scouts had done it right.
I would say: make sure you're talking,
put your hands in your pockets, and it's really hard
as an adult leader
if your SPL is not up to the job.
you know six months or a year
they'll learn a lot.
and if your patrol leaders are good,
your troop is going to be fine.
you know people are learning
when they're making mistakes.
can you, as a senior patrol,
make any mistakes?
I made a lot of mistakes
the way I organized the patrols
to begin with.
I'm still not sure
if that was the best way or not
and I'm still firm about this
and I do think that
once they had been started
they probably shouldn't have been changed
just because I saw the aftermath
of what happened after that.
but
I'm still not sure whether I had
set everything up right to begin with
and I know for sure
that my communication skills
were definitely lacking
in a lot of areas.
I guess probably the way I
tried to present my ideas
after the scoutmaster
and to the older scouters
probably wasn't the best way.
a lot of this stuff.
it's hard to see what I'm missing,
but I know that I am missing a lot,
not only in my communication skills
but kind of my way to actually step back
and look at the overall picture.
and I do know that
after this tenure as
senior patrol leader
I definitely know a lot more about
not only communication but also organization
and troop organization and all that stuff.
I know a ton more about that
than before I started.
so a lot of that was through mistakes I made.
it's not a failure
if you learn something from it.
it's really important
looking back on it. if you had to do it again,
you would do it better, and the next time
you would do it better
instead of making the same mistakes
over and over again
and you probably won't ever be SPL again.
someday you'll be
something else-
head of a scrum team,
making software,
working as a manager
or being a scoutmaster- who knows.
but those lessons will have been learned
from mistakes over again.
so those aren't failures
and it's good that you're rolling them
around in your mind now.
that's really good.
as scout leaders, we're in danger sometimes
of
trying to keep everything looking good
and trying to have
a really smooth, efficient program
and that
when things
are a little chaotic
or our youth leaders are making mistakes,
they reflect poorly on us
and so we try and coerce
some changes to the way things are done.
what we're doing
right now is we're talking to
somebody who has benefited from going
through this kind of process of
giving everything a try,
making a few mistakes along the way,
maybe doubting a little bit
and everything. but that is
the whole value
of that youth leader
experience in my mind
is getting to go through
that process
and being able to
do that as independent
from somebody
making judgments about your decisions
or trying to coerce you into doing things a certain way.
I just don't think there's anything
that can replace that.
Scouting has actually
changed one of my
little evaluation methods for
whether I want to take advice from somebody,
and
my new question is:
have they made more mistakes than I have?
but
if they have made fewer
mistakes than I have,
then they probably do not know more
well. that's probably why people listen
to us, Walter,
because
decades
put all together,
we have what about 5 or 6 decades
of mistakes.
you're being very kind,
so
make the mistakes while you're young,
yes,
and make the mistakes while you're millage.
make the mistakes while you're old,
but you're doing something.
and it all sounds a little trite
because we hear this all the time:
if you're not making mistakes,
you're not doing anything.
you know, Enoch, the things that you
went through as SPL.
it's not natural
for most adults
who are
teachers,
managers,
possibly military folks,
it's not natural for them
to do the best thing for you
and your fellow scouts.
we don't always do the best job at letting you
do what you need to do
to learn that,
and so we hope to encourage adult leaders
to do that.
I'm curious actually, Enoch:
is there another
place where you could have made the same mistakes
or learned the same things?
any place else-
sports or school-
where you could have learned the things that you learned
in scouts?
no, not so far.
maybe later, when I get more out into the
workforce and stuff,
I will have seen that
if I hadn't learned these stuff earlier I would have been learning it now.
but so far
scouting has been the only place-
and I credit the whole
commitment for this-
scouting has been the only place that I've really
truly developed my character.
another part of the article you wrote for me was
the relationship
between you and your dad in scouts.
tell me a little bit about that.
well, I definitely know that
I owe most, if not all,
of what I was able to do with scouting
and what I became through scouting
to my dad.
like I said in the article,
he didn't have any scouting experience.
I joined the troop.
he didn't have any experience as a scout master,
scout leader or even as a scout.
he wanted to be involved in the troop.
he wanted to be involved in the camping trips and stuff.
now sometimes his work would prevent him from doing that,
but I always knew that he wanted
to be there and he wanted to
and he cared about the way things were happening.
and
the more time I spent in scouting,
the more time I was able to contrast
this
with the other scouts and their relationships.
unfortunately, you know a lot of the other scouts
I could see they didn't have the same
relationship with their dad that I had
and I can see that their dad-
you know, often times
even their mom- just brought them to the scout meetings.
maybe their mom stayed for a few minutes
or whatever. but you know,
sometimes I couldn't even tell who the dads were
and
the only time I even saw a dad
was at maybe a court of honor.
so I became really
appreciative of the role of a dad-
you know, father- in the life of the scout,
because
he communicated with me, he talked to me,
he gave me feedback. he said: you know
well, when you said this, you really came across this way-
and I know you didn't mean to,
but that's the way you came across- and he really helped
just by talking with me,
giving me feedback and stuff.
he just gave me so much advice.
I can't think him enough for that.
Enoch, do you do any canoeing
or backpacking?
oh yeah, when I can,
does your dad go?
he has, yes, he has.
have you found your?
have you found your roles,
beginning to reverse over time
from when you were,
when you were a little kid
and he was kind of looking after you
and sort of watching to see if you set your tent up
to you. now kind of looking
after him and checking up on him
occasionally and
okay, I guess. so
I'm not,
I wouldn't quite put it in a way.
you know, roles reversed,
but I can see
how our relationship has kind of
changed and matured over time
as I matured
and
more on the level,
eye to eye, as opposed to dad,
down to kid,
yeah well, yeah, kind of
I still look at-
and I never won't be able to do this-
I still look at him as my dad, my father.
that that relationship,
but I do. you know,
I do more things, I guess a lot
more things on my own, and
he hasn't been able to participate
near as much just because of his work.
you know, while I regretted that
he still spent the time to talk
with me and more became
an advisor rather than
actually coming through and helping me
to step through things, I started
my Eagle Scout project which
I've been working on for quite a while now.
he's been
a really great source of advice,
but he hasn't done anything really for me
as far as I have to write all the
emails, I have to make all the communications.
I have to do all that, but
I still rely on his advice and communication.
I still say, you know, hey, how does this
sound? does this sound like I'm coming across the wrong way
and stuff like that? so
it has changed.
so, yeah, that's really your question. yeah,
yeah, one of the
bits from training, from the
older wood batch courses: use
your resources, and your resources
are pretty much everybody
you know and your family
especially.
now you've been through this process.
what's happening right now
is you've got a lot of other scout masters listening in
and they have listened to this
story and they are going
to be thinking, yeah, this is kind
of familiar, this is happening
right now in my troop, or
I had this happen in my troop, or
this could certainly happen with my troop.
so, Enoch, here's your big chance.
what do you tell these guys?
I can't really think that I would be giving
advice to people. you know, of course
we've had a lot more experience in scouting than I have,
but, like I said
in my post, the responsibility
of the senior patrol leader
and the patrol leader and stuff- it does mean a lot.
I took it a little bit more
seriously than a lot of my peers
did. but still
I know from experience and talking
with them and stuff that they take it seriously too
and although they may
not take the initiative, a lot of times
it's easier to let somebody else kind of run
and head the show and stuff-
but they really do take the responsibility
seriously. but the only way
they will take it really seriously
is if you
take it seriously too as the scout master.
I was reading in a book
about scouting the other day.
I was talking about how the scout master
should making like an announcement to the troop,
the whole. he should follow the chain of command down
and allow the patrol leaders to spread that
onto their patrol and stuff like that-
just little things like that-
shows the scouts that hey, the scout master-
this guy I respect- is
depending upon me to do this.
he's depending upon me to
to help my patrol and make sure my patrol
knows and is on the right track,
and that is really important.
and I think the more I've
learned in scouting, the more important
I've seen that that is the responsibility
of the patrol leaders and the
basically the scout leaders.
so what you're telling me
then is that
even when
it doesn't look like these guys care,
or that they take
their responsibility very seriously.
they really do, and they want you,
they want the leader to
to recognize that and say:
you know I'm counting on you, I need you to do this for me
and you know I can't help
you. you know you've got to be able to figure this out on your own
and you know it's a little different.
of course it's different. they've never done
something like this before and often times,
if they're really young, like 11 or 12,
they there. it's just a whole new
paradigm in their life to kind of be a
take charge and be a leader. but
they do have that.
they do have that inside of them and they
want to. they want to,
they want to help hold that responsibility
and they want to live up to it.
yeah, that's a very powerful message.
that's very, very powerful and that's
coming from somebody who is
younger than us and
still is a scout. one of the things I
love about our troop is that
the scouts
will will step up
and say when a
if an adult is
trying to run things, they will say,
no, that can be
really, really difficult to do, and
and they'll step in for someone else
and it's a. it's a great
thing because
that's you know, they've really
picked up what it's about.
Enoch, if you had joined
at 11,
10 and a half or 11, would you like
to have been a 13 or 13
and a half year old Eagle Scout?
well, if I were to go back to
to being 11,
I wouldn't really know. I mean,
and I would probably want to get it
as soon as possible and the thought of being
a really young Eagle Scout would appeal
to me. but
from my perspective now,
I wouldn't have it
any other way. I mean,
for instance, I
I kind of felt this way a little bit earlier
whenever I was a,
a star scout,
I think I.
what I did was I passed up the opportunity
one time I could have had a
board of review for live scout, but I didn't.
I waited till the next term, which is, like
you know, three or four months later
after that, whenever I could go in for a
review and I. the reason I waited
is because I felt
that I didn't have enough
experience to hold the. you know the
title and you know I found
out that that's that's not kind of a way
of looking at things a lot of other people don't
really look at, but
the way it is now.
I can tell you that if I would have got my
Eagle Scout at 13, I would
have missed out on so,
so many lessons that I've learned through my
project. now I chose something
that was kind of difficult. so
you know my project for over a year now
but
it's really challenged me. I mean,
I'm working with organization and
different skills that you know are
similar to stuff adults
experience and adults have told me that
and I know that
this gives me such a great
advantage to go through this now and
learn all this now and be really
challenged at this stage of my life,
because
I will. I will be a lot
more prepared for whenever I get older.
does that answer the question?
Yeah, that's,
that's an amazing answer.
great answer.
What is your project?
It's a bit of a different project
and I always kind of
fear explaining it to other people because
some people are like: what in the world is this?
but have any of you all
heard of amateur radio, ham radio?
A little bit.
I think Walter has heard of that a little
bit.
So there's a huge network
of these amateur radio operators
around the United States who do a lot
of community service. they do
weather spotting anyway my dad
has been into that for quite a while,
since he was really young, and he kind
of introduced me to that and so
I'm a licensed amateur radio operator
as well. I just kind of
had the idea
to install a amateur radio repeater.
so basically what this is going to do
and is going to take
transmissions from a little short
range transmitters
and be able to transmit it over
quite a wide range of areas around
this location, and I hope, my hope
is that this will be used for a lot of
stuff like storm tracking
and that kind of stuff
That sounds familiar at all.
Peters are critical in emergency response
and the
slogan is: when all else fails,
and with your radio,
Exactly.
Walter is quite an enthusiast
For the past. like I don't know three years,
three or four years now- I've been going
down to the National Scouting Museum
in Irving in October for
the annual jamboree on the
air that they put on, and I've really
enjoyed that.
Yes, jamboree on the air is the largest
scouting event
every year,
700,000 people.
I got a post on my blog.
if anyone is interested in ham radio,
I got a post on my blog. you'll have to
go back in the history a little bit,
the archives at the blog, but
it's on reasons
that I think everybody should be
involved in ham radio, or amateur
radio as it's called. so if
anybody's interested, just check that out.
Well, I certainly
appreciate everybody joining us for a
Scott master panel discussion. Enoch,
very interesting,
inspiring stuff. Really appreciate
you being with us. Well, thank you so much
for having me. I really enjoyed it
and I hope that
somebody maybe can learn through the mistakes I made.
so
That's what we're all doing. Walter
Underwood, K6WRU.
clear.
Larry, we really do appreciate
you being here. Walter, we appreciate you being here
and we look forward to doing this again
next time. You're welcome, Clark, it's been great.
Well, thanks so much for listening
to this edition of the scout master podcast.
now here's how to keep in touch.
You can read the scout master blog
at scoutmastercgcom
and you can subscribe to receive updates
to the blog there by email.
Subscribe to the scout master podcast
on iTunes and when you do- and you know
you have a chance- go ahead and leave a comment
or review a rating.
You can also access the podcast
on your mobile device through Stitcher Smart Radio
and you get details about how to do that
at stitchercom. Now you can
call and leave a voicemail, comment or question
or a shout out by going to
scoutmastercgcom
if you want to give a shout out link.
you can experience the wonders of
scoutmastercgcom through the vast
panorama of social media
outlets. Join the 1600 others that are
following us at
scoutmasterblog on Facebook. You can
tweet scoutmastercg on twitter
and, for admittance to the exclusive
scoutmastercg circle, search for us
on google plus.
Well, if none of that makes any sense at all,
you can just email me. that's right,
email Clark Green with your comments
or wild ideas at
scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet.
The scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster
podcast are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America, nor are they
adorst or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
no, It's just me
talking into a microphone, trying to lend a hand
to scout leaders and maybe have a little bit of fun
along the way. that's it. But before we go,
let's hear from our founder, Sir
Robert Baden-Palis. Sir Robert,
Good luck to you
and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir. Until
next time.